genauer betrachten aber es ist ein
deutliches indiz dafür dass sich die
drei parteien einig geworden sind
zumindest in dem punkt dass die
koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen wollen
wir haben im laufe des vormittags jetzt
auch erfahren über die deutsche presse
agentur dass die gremien der grünen
beispielsweise ein erweitertes
sondierungsteam von 24 mitgliedern aber
auch der parteirat der grünen sich schon
mit den ergebnissen der gespräche der
sondierungsgespräche befasst hat heute
im laufe des vormittags und mittags auch
der fdp-bundesvorstand so meldet die
deutsche presseagentur ist schon mit den
ergebnissen befasst gewesen gegen mittag
soll sich die spd-bundestagsfraktion in
einer schaltkonferenz über die
ergebnisse informieren und all diese
informationen zusammengenommen plus der
information dass es um 13 uhr hier eine
kurze pressekonferenz geben soll der
spitze der delegation wie es heißt da
stehen drei mikrofone da müssen jetzt
noch mal aus würfeln welche drei denn
auch tatsächlich da nachher stehen ist
ja nicht mehr lange hin bis wir das
wissen all das macht natürlich sehr sehr
deutlich dass diese drei parteien
koalitionsverhandlungen führen werden
und wir zeigen ihnen noch ein bisschen
weil wir ja auch ein wenig zeit haben
von der szenerie hier unten direkt
hinter mir sehen sie schon jede menge
kameras in großer erwartung dass die
protagonisten der pressekonferenz hier
möglicherweise die rolltreppe runter
kommen aus der ersten etage hier im hub
27 und da sehen wir aber noch im moment
relativ wenig kräfte claudia roth können
sie sicherlich gut erkennen auch aus der
ferne die da oben steht und diesen
ganzen pulk hier unten betrachtet es
könnte aber auch sagen und dass die drei
die die pressekonferenz nachher machen
hier durch die aufzugstür kommen die
sehen sie auch dahinter all diese
möglichkeiten sind da aber sie sehen
gleichzeitig wir sind gut aufgestellt
wir werden das hier rechtzeitig unten
live ins bild setzen können und dann
wären wir hören beziehungsweise
bestätigt bekommen was hier alle seit
dem beginn des vormittages eigentlich
mutmaßen wir sind insofern ein klein
wenig überrascht dass es doch sehr
schnell gegangen ist denn wenn es stimmt
dass die gremien schon im laufe des
vormittags darüber beraten haben dann
muss heute schon sehr früh
hyde darüber bestanden haben dass man in
koalitionsgespräche geht es gab ja
allerlei vorkehrungen beispielsweise
auch bei den grünen die am sonntag jetzt
sicher einen länderrat veranstalten
werden um sich da das okay zu holen für
die
koalitionsgespräche delegation die dann
am start sein werden also von daher war
die mutmaßung schon sehr groß dass die
drei parteien hier zusammenkommen aber
man musste eben auf der anderen seite
auch immer feststellen dass die
diskrepanzen in vielen themenbereichen
nicht nur bei finanzen nicht nur beim
thema haushalt steuern oder beim thema
klimaschutz noch sehr weit auseinander
sind und insofern war natürlich immer
auch noch die möglichkeit gegeben dass
man sich zu einem gemeinsamen ende kommt
andererseits sind die konstellation ja
auch durchaus so dass die option die
alternativen derzeit relativ rar gesät
sind so dass das wiederum die
wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht hat dass man
zumindest in koalitionsgespräche geht
wie die ausgehen das kann man natürlich
heute noch nicht sagen ja wir wissen
nicht wie weit man jetzt gekommen ist
bei den sondierungen und ob da die
ganzen dicken brocken noch draußen
vorgelassen wurden aber man kann 1
festhalten was wir uns alle natürlich
sehr ungewöhnlich war weil berlin
irgendwie dann quatsch diesen verein zu
sein scheint manchmal zumindest
man hat nicht geredet also man hat
wirklich eisern geschwiegen hat man sich
tatsächlich richtig gut dran gehalten
erstaunlich oder
das ist in der tat erstaunlich aber das
war ja im vorfeld eine der maske haben
mit denen diese drei parteien in diese
sanierungen auch die formulierungen
schon gegangen sind dass man gesagt hat
wir wollen ein vertrauensverhältnis
zueinander aufbauen wir haben im
wahlkampf und teilweise durchaus mächtig
und teilweise auch heftig bekämpft auch
mit durchaus auch gelegentlich
persönlichen attacken wie es da von
verschiedenen seiten gegeneinander
jeweils gab und deswegen brauchte es
erst mal ein forum in dem
vertraulichkeit regiert in dem man in
vertraulicher runde und dann auch
wirklich unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit auf sich über wirklich
schwierige punkte unterhalten konnte
deswegen bin ich guck mal gerade zur
seite weil es etwas unruhig wird in der
ersten etage und siehe da auch schon den
generalsekretär übrigens der fdp und den
der spd und auch der
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen wir
können also ziemlich sicher sein dass
das ganze hier in wenigen minuten über
die bühne geht ich muss gerade noch mal
gucken ich wollte einen punkt aufnehmen
stephan kulle den sie gesagt haben ich
glaube nicht dass alle schwierigen
punkte schon ausgeräumt sind ich glaube
dass man aber sich darauf verständigt
hat zumindest wie man über diese
schwierigen klippen über diese
schwierigen punkte gemeinsam hinweg
kommen kann also es wird sicherlich noch
jede menge diskussionen geben und es
wird da bin ich auch ziemlich sicher
auch in den koalitionsverhandlungen
momente geben wo es sind stocken gerät
wo es schwierigkeiten gibt wo es dann
auch wieder heißen könnte spitz auf
knopf stehen die ganze sache arbeiten
nichtsdestotrotz hat man sich über die
ganz ganz schwierige punkte hier
verständig zumindest über wege wie man
diese schwierigen punkte überwinden kann
vielleicht auch schon erste schritte
gegangen ich wüsste ich jetzt gerne
tatsächlich was in diesen zwölf seiten
papier drinsteht dann wären wir
vielleicht ein bisschen schlauer aber
weil es so knapp gekommen ist vor diesem
schaltgespräch war das natürlich leider
nicht möglich wir hoffen und denken dass
wir in der pressekonferenz gleich ein
klein wenig erfahren um das ganze wieder
rund zu machen und zu ihrer frage
zurückzukommen ja das schweigegelübde
wie es häufig genannt worden ist oder
die fünf disziplinen wie marco buschmann
der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der fdp-bundestagsfraktion das genannt
hat das hat funktioniert das ist
beibehalten worden ist es nichts
substanzielles raus gedrungen und das
ist sicherlich schon mal eine ganz gute
basis für die drei beteiligten deren
vorstellungen wie gesagt in manchen
bereichen in manchen gebieten doch ganz
schön auseinander gehen vielleicht ist
das ja so ein bisschen dieser geist der
hinter dem ganzen steckt den man ja
gerade am anfang schon am tag nach der
wahl daraus wird also ich stefan
entschuldigen sie ich glaube es tut sich
tatsächlich was und ich habe ihn selber
gesagt dass sie generalsekretären nicht
die pressekonferenz mutmaßlich machen
werden deswegen hatte ich die beiden die
drei zwar gerade im blick die ganze zeit
aber die eigentlichen entscheidenden
protagonisten sind jetzt auch
tatsächlich über den aufzug bekommen wir
zeigen ihnen hier noch mal eine ganze
reihe von
unterhändler der vergangenen tage
entweder im city cube ihr leben angehen
der messe beziehungsweise hier im hub 27
beraten und verhandelt haben schauen
jetzt auch mal wie möglicherweise
idealerweise auf das bild der anderen
kamera wie wir aufgestellt haben und die
ihnen dann die pressekonferenz sie jetzt
gleich beginnt ein bisschen besser
einfangen kann ich habe sehr ein monitor
der sehr sehr weit weg ist und kann nur
mutmaßen aber muss gar nicht länger
mutmaßen denn die pressekonferenz
beginnt
guten tag meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen kollegen ich begrüße sie
herzlich zu den presse statement
anlässlich der sondierungsgespräche von
spd grünen und fdp
als gesprächspartner stehen ihnen zur
verfügung der kanzlerkandidat der spd
olaf scholz
die
parteivorsitzende der grünen annalena
baerbock
der parteivorsitzende der fdp christian
lindner die parteivorsitzende der spd
saskia esken der parteivorsitzende der
grünen robert habeck und der
parteivorsitzende der spd norbert walter
borjans
das wort hat olaf scholz bitteschön
einen schönen guten tag ich freue mich
sie alle hier zu sehen wir haben in
dieser woche intensiv gearbeitet auch
gestern noch einmal bis heute
frühmorgens
miteinander viel gesprochen und geredet
um all die dinge vorzubereiten die für
die heutigen beratungen dann
erforderlich war und tatsächlich ist es
gelungen wir haben uns auf einen papier
einen text zur sondierung verständigt
der jetzt die grundlage für die
entscheidungen in den parteien bilden
kann und aus der perspektive die ich für
mich formulieren will ist das auch ein
sehr gutes ergebnis es macht deutlich
dass in deutschland eine regierung
gebildet werden kann die dafür sorge
tragen möchten dass wir einen
fortschritt erreichen ein fortschritt
der möglich und notwendig ist in vielen
vielen feldern unserer
gesellschaftlichen entwicklung unserer
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung und auch im
hinblick auf die aufgaben die wir als
land in europa haben das haben wir
konkretisiert in vielen fragestellungen
die für uns wichtig sind ganz besonders
geht es um die modernisierung unseres
gemeinwesens wir wollen dafür sorge
tragen dass viele verwaltungsabläufe
schneller und digitaler werden dass wir
aber auch alle notwendigen
entscheidungen die für den ökonomischen
und investiven aufbruch in deutschland
notwendig sind so treffen dass sie
schnell zustande kommen kann und dann
gibt es viele felder für die wir das für
uns in anspruch nehmen und wo wir das
voranbringen wollen dass eine große
thema ist die industrielle modell
regierung unseres landes die so gelingen
muss dass wir es gleichzeitig schaffen
den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten
und das bedeutet dass wir einen massiven
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
brauchen damit es möglich ist dass wir
so schnell wie möglich auf die nutzung
fossiler ressourcen verzichten können
genau das haben wir uns miteinander
vorgenommen es wird das größte
industrielle modernisierungsprojekt ist
deutschland wahrscheinlich seit über 100
jahren
durchgeführt hat und das wird unser
wirtschaft und unseren wirtschaftlichen
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten sehr nutzen
wir haben gleichzeitig sorge dafür
getragen dass die gesellschaft
zusammenhält es gibt fragen die viele
von uns bewegen und die wichtig sind
schaffen wir es dass die kinder gute
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten haben ohne
dass kinderarmut weiter unser land
begleitet kriegen wir es hin dass
genügend wohnungen in deutschland gebaut
werden und dass wir das große drängende
problem des wohnungsmangels lösen können
wir sicherstellen dass die bürgerinnen
bürger dieses landes sich darauf
verlassen können dass sie eine sichere
und stabile rente haben das genau haben
wir vereinbart dass das für die nächsten
jahre gelingen soll gleichzeitig aber
auch sichergestellt dass die
rentenversicherung mit zusätzlichen
mitteln ausgestattet wird um in der lage
zu sein dass sie dann auch die
demografischen herausforderungen
sicherer bewältigen werden bewältigen
kann als ohne das und wir haben uns fest
vorgenommen dass wir für respekt und
zusammenhalt sorgen dass spielt die
frage des mindestlohns eine große rolle
und der besseren und tariflichen
bezahlung in vielen bereichen unserer
gesellschaft alles frage über die wir
uns verständigt haben den vielen vielen
anderen der eine rolle spielen und
insgesamt kann man sehr spüren hier ist
ein aufbruch möglich getragen von den
dreien parteien dinge zusammenkommen für
mich persönlich dass wir dich gerne noch
sagen ist es sehr bemerkenswert wie
vertrauensvoll und konstruktiv die
gespräche über auch unterschiedliche
ausgangspositionen stattfinden das ist
etwas das ich als sehr sehr wohltuend
empfinden weil es schon jetzt während
der sondierung dann hoffentlich bei
koalitionsverhandlungen und noch viel
mehr wenn es darum geht miteinander zu
regieren dazu beitragen kann dass hier
das angepackt wird was für deutschland
notwendig ist das haben wir uns
vorgenommen und wenn die zusammenarbeit
weiter so gut klappt dann glaube ich
wird das auch eine gute zukunft werden
für unser land
auch von unterseite schönen guten tag
schön dass sie alle hier sind und
herzlichen dank auch an ihr verständnis
in den letzten tagen dass wir sehr
vertrauensvoll miteinander gearbeitet
haben weil in diesen besonderen moment
wo drei parteien zusammen kommen auch
aus unterschiedlichen richtungen
zusammenkommen die grundlage dafür dass
wir hier heute einen vorschlag für
unsere parteien machen können mit blick
auf ein gemeinsames sondierungs papier
vor allen dingen war dass es ein
vertrauensvolles gespräch gibt wo man
auch offen über unterschiedlichkeiten
sprechen kann um dann gemeinsame wege
und brücken zu finden und das ist uns
gelungen gestern nacht noch bis in den
frühen morgen in intensiven gesprächen
gelungen einen vorschlag für eine reform
und fortschritts koalition auf den weg
zu bringen um das nächste jahrzehnt
wirklich als jahrzehnt der erneuerung zu
nutzen und damit wir nicht nur auf den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner weiter
politik in diesem land machen sondern in
einer fortschritts koalition auch für
eine wirkliche erneuerung sorgen war es
wichtig dass bei drei unterschiedlichen
parteien ein verständnis da ist dass
jeder auch mal was gibt dass wir die
großen fragen unserer zeit auch wirklich
mutig angehen können und mutig angehen
können bedeutet dann auch den mut zu
haben entscheidungen zu treffen damit
wir bei den zukunftsfragen wirklich in
diesem jahrzehnt die erneuerung auf den
weg bringen können das ist vor allen
dingen die große frage der
klimagerechten gesellschaft des
klimagerechten wohlstands und eine
erneuerung der sozialen marktwirtschaft
hin zu einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft in deutschland und damit
auch in europa zu verankern und zugleich
dieses jahrzehnt des fortschritts für
eine modernisierung unseres landes für
eine digitalisierung unseres landes
gemeinsam zu nutzen und dafür die
entsprechenden gelder investitionen
gerade auch mit forschung und
entwicklung bereit zu stellen damit
dieses jahrzehnt gemeinsam genutzt
werden kann und das im herzen europas
und auch in der verantwortung in der
welt weil es auch darum geht wenn wir
europa zum klimaneutralen kontinent
gestalten wollen zugleich die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unseres industriestandort deutschland zu
nutzen und die modernisierung des
staates auch im ausdruck dessen wie wir
gemeinsam regieren nämlich im sinne der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu gestalten als
eine regierung die einlädt die lernfähig
ist und vor allen dingen die im dialog
mit den menschen in unserem land politik
für die zukünftigen generationen
betreibt
guten morgen auch in meiner seite sie
sehen hier die vorsitzenden und die
spitzenkandidatinnen dreier parteien die
eigene traditionen und die eigene
sichtweisen haben und die haben wir in
den vergangenen tagen den intensiven
gesprächen eingebracht um auszuloten wie
es uns gelingen kann ein bündnis zu
schmieden ein bündnis das unser land
voranbringt und wir haben spd auf
spd-seite norbert walter borjans und ich
gerade im moment gemeinsam mit olaf
scholz unsere parteigremien darüber
informiert dass wir sehr zuversichtlich
sind nach diesen sehr intensiven und
vertrauensvollen
gesprächen die auch dazu geführt haben
dass wir gemeinsamkeiten erarbeiten
konnten dass wir auch einigungen
erzielen kunden in konnten den
entscheidenden fragen dass wir empfehlen
können in koalitionsverhandlungen zu
treten mit dem mit den bündner mit den
bündnispartnern mit bündnis 90/die
grünen und mit den freien demokraten und
ein solches bündnis dass wir uns das
vorstellen das soll die modernisierung
des landes voran bringen die
modernisierung unseres staates auch der
regierung der gesellschaft und die
vielen veränderungen die vor uns liegen
die jetzt schon die angesprochen worden
sind sowohl die sozial ökologische
transformation unserer industrie aber
auch unsere gesellschaft der wirtschaft
als auch andere veränderungen wie
beispielsweise der digitale wandel
verlangen den menschen viel ab und
deswegen kommt es uns darauf an dass wir
den menschen den respekt auch bezeugen
und dass wir ihnen auch die sicherheit
geben dass sie in diesen veränderungen
auch alle mitgenommen werden
meine damen meine herren die
letzten tage waren geprägt von einem
besonderen stil es haben sich drei
politische kräfte getroffen die in einem
sehr diskreten rahmen
sehr ernsthaft mit
neugier auf die positionen des
gegenübers gespräche organisiert haben
allein dieser stil markiert schon eine
zäsur in der politischen kultur
deutschlands wir haben gemerkt dass die
art und weise wie wir uns mit den
zukunfts herausforderungen
beschäftigen viele menschen in unserem
land beeindruckt hat das alleine durch
die ernsthaftigkeit die wir gesprochen
haben viele menschen hoffnung geschöpft
haben dass ein neuer aufbruch für unser
land möglich ist das hat bei uns
und die mein eindruck ist bei allen
beteiligten den möglichkeitsraum
erweitert und auch neue fantasie neue
politische fantasie möglich gemacht die
fdp versteht sich als eine partei der
politischen mitte
diese gesprächs konstellation auf der
bundesebene ist für uns neu wir sehen
darin aber eine chance wenn so
unterschiedliche parteien sich auf
gemeinsame herausforderungen und
lösungsangebote verständigen könnten
dann liegt darin auch eine chance unser
land insgesamt
zusammenzuführen dann besteht die chance
dass eine mögliche koalition größer wird
als die summe ihrer teile
wir haben intensiv gesprochen und wir
haben uns nicht um formelkompromisse
bemüht
wir haben mit der
eigenart gebrochen politische
unterschiede zu zu decken sondern wir
haben uns um klare
richtungsentscheidungen bemüht dabei
kommt es immer zu einem geben und nehmen
aber fortschritt setzt voraus dass es
klare richtung anzeigen gibt und solche
klaren richtung san zeigen die haben wir
erreicht aus meiner sicht will ich
hervorheben dass es klare finanzielle
leitplanken gibt wie die nachhaltigkeit
der öffentlichen finanzen mit dem
respekt vor den grenzen der
belastungsfähigkeit der menschen
verbinden auch entlastungs perspektiven
etwa im bereich der stromkosten werden
aufgezeigt wir haben zum zweiten ein
programm skizziert für die
entbürokratisierung und
entfesselung unseres landes damit
private und öffentliche vorhaben wieder
möglich werden
wir wollen uns bemühen um
wettbewerbsfähigkeit auch durch private
und öffentliche investitionen in einem
erneuerten
sozial-ökologischen ordnungsrahmen der
marktwirtschaft wir wollen einen
neustart für den sozialen aufstieg von
sozialen aufstieg erleichtern von
zuverdienstgrenzen bei einem neuen
bürgergeld über initiativen in der
bildung bis hin zu verbesserungen bei
der altersversorgung der menschen und
nicht zuletzt haben wir ein gemeinsames
verständnis dafür gewonnen dass unsere
gesellschaft insgesamt einen
liberalisierung schub benötigt dass wir
eine modernisierung unserer
gesellschaftspolitik brauchen das also
für die freiheit der individuen stärken
wollen wir sind überzeugt nach diesen
gesprächen
dass
es lange zeit
keine vergleichbare chance gegeben hat
gesellschaft wirtschaft und staat zu
modernisieren
lange zeit hat es keine vergleichbare
modernisierungs chance gegeben wie jetzt
und deshalb wollen wir diese chance
nicht verstreichen lassen
unser sondierungsteam wird den gremien
der fdp am montag deshalb empfehlen in
koalitionsgespräche einzutreten wir
glauben der große gewinner einer solchen
koalition wird am ende nicht eine
einzelne partei sein sondern unser land
aus den gesprächen der letzten tage und
der letzten stunden wir trafen uns nicht
unweit von hier unterschieden nicht
umwelt von hier im frühen morgen ist
eine stabile grundlage
entstanden die ist auch unser partei
ermöglicht hoffentlich ermöglicht in
koalitionsgespräche einzusteigen ein
teil der gespräche finden sie
verschriftlicht jetzt bei einem papier
das zusammenfasst was wir erarbeitet
haben in den letzten tagen und wochen
wir haben jetzt unsererseits danach
heute morgen die gremien sondierungsteam
und parteirat schon befasst und werden
jetzt am sonntag unserem länder hat das
ist der kleine parteitag ebenfalls
empfehlen aufgrund der gesammelten
erfahrungen und des papieres das jetzt
ausgeteilt wird in koalitionsgespräche
einzusteigen ich stimme den vor
rednerinnen ausdrücklich zu dass in den
letzten
tagen aus einer
unklaren
ausgegangenen bundestagswahl eine
dynamik entstanden ist die diesen sich
abzeichnenden regierungsbündnis eine
echte schubkraft geben kann und es ist
die dynamik und weniger die
schnittmengen die ausgelotet worden die
die hoffnung darauf setzt dass
tatsächlich
großes geleistet werden kann
wenn man nachts lange redet dann lernt
man sich ganz gut kennen
und das sagen wir mit großem respekt es
ist tatsächlich so dass die diskretion
und hohe professionalität der
verschiedenen partner es ermöglicht
haben so schnell zu diesem ergebnis zu
kommen und eben diese dynamik auszulösen
wenn drei parteien miteinander reden und
die auch aus unterschiedlichen
politischen
wertevorstellungen stammen ist völlig
klar dass es zumutung gibt und dass die
zumutung getragen und beschlossen werden
müssen um danach gemeinsames größeres
möglich zu machen dass das so gelungen
ist ist nicht selbstverständlich gewesen
und zeigt christian lindner hat es eben
angesprochen dass wir bereits in zu
klaren entscheidungen nicht zu einer
politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners sondern tatsächlich uns zu
entscheiden welches projekt wie
angegangen wird beziehungsweise im suche
nach neuen projekten auch eine eigene
kreativität oder eben fantasie entsteht
das kann weit tragen und so hoffen
annalena baerbock und ich dass unsere
partei den weg zu koalitionsgesprächen
frei macht wie weit es tragen kann kann
man an zwei aspekten in diesem
sondierungs papier gut ablesen es ist ja
bekannt dass die finanzpolitischen
vorstellungen zumindestens von fdp und
grünen weit auseinander lagen und
trotzdem ist es gelungen den parteien
insofern rechnung zu tragen dass die
belastungen die die fdp nicht wollte
nicht kommen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger und trotzdem genug
investitionsspielraum geschaffen werden
wird das die zukunftsinvestition in
digitalisierung in klimaschutz in
forschung und entwicklung bestimmt
werden können insofern ein sehr
zufriedenstellendes ergebnis macht
langen gesprächen und verhandlungen
es gibt einen zweiten würde ich sagen
glutkern die sich abzeichnenden bündnis
und das ist die gesellschaftliche
modernisierung wir würden ist so
übersetzen dass die politik der
lebenswirklichkeit des landes endlich
rechnung trägt menschen die in
lebensform leben die bisher keinen
rechtsstatus haben werden ihn bekommen
können wir werden die vielfalt des
landes auch juristisch und im
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
abbilden und so dass tatsächlich im
bereich der gesellschaftlichen politik
eine reine ein ausschluss mit der
realität des lebens von vielen menschen
in diesem land gelingen kann das ist ein
großes ziel und wir freuen uns und
hoffen darauf ist dann in den nächsten
jahren verwirklichen zu können
ja meine damen und herren wir haben in
den letzten tagen oft miteinander
gesprochen wir haben gestern und heute
nacht sehr lange miteinander gesprochen
und die wichtigste währung in diesen
gesprächen war dass wir respekt
voreinander hatten dass wir dadurch
vertrauen zueinander gewonnen haben und
dass wir uns gesagt haben wir sitzen
hier nicht weil jeder für seine
wählerinnen und wähler allein
verantwortlich ist sondern weil wir
erstens gemeinsam verantwortlich sind
und weil wir auch verantwortlich sind
für die menschen die uns nicht gewählt
haben es ging nicht darum nur den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner ausfindig
zu machen sondern es ging darum dass uns
bewusst ist wir haben eine sehr große
aufgabe als die drei parteien im
deutschen bundestag die wirklich in der
in der zeit in der lage sind
verantwortung zu übernehmen die eine
gemeinsame vorstellung davon haben wie
fortschritt in der zukunft aussehen kann
und die dadurch aber auch ihre
unterschiedlichen akzente zur geltung
bringen konnten es ging um viele von
vornherein fest stehende große
gemeinsamkeiten das uns klar ist wir
müssen noch einen zacken zulegen im
klimaschutz wir müssen technologisch
wieder weiter an die spitze kommen die
digitalisierung ist eine riesige
herausforderung aber eben auch immer in
sozialer verantwortung in dem wissen
dass
sicherheit im wandel
nur möglich ist mit sicherheit durch
wandel und vor diesem hintergrund glaube
ich haben wir uns gut zusammengefunden
wir haben schwerpunkte in den feldern
die ich eben genannt habe gesetzt wir
haben eben auch gegeben und genommen und
wir können mit gutem gewissen für das
land insgesamt unseren gremien in der
partei vorschlagen dass wir auf der
grundlage dieser sondierungen wir sind
ja noch nicht in koalitionsverhandlungen
jetzt koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen
sollten dass wir viele dieser punkte die
wir angesprochen haben vertiefen sollten
und da geht es eben auf der einen seite
darum was ist in diesem land alles was
steht an was ist zu investieren wie wärs
die finanzierung sichergestellt und ich
glaube dass die sondierung gezeigt hat
dass das in ein gleichgewicht zu bringen
ist mit dem jeder der partner leben kann
und vor allen dingen mit dem wir
insgesamt das land nach vorne bringen
das macht uns zuversichtlich
dass wir nachdem wir heute schon einmal
den parteivorstand der spd informiert
haben heute nachmittag nochmal auf der
grundlage unseres gemeinsamen papiers
zusammentreten und auch um das votum
bitten info koalitionsverhandlungen
einzutreten und die dann hoffentlich
auch zu einem erfolg zum guten erfolg
für dieses land zu bringen danke
vielen dank bevor wir zu ihren fragen
kommen ein kurzer hinweis noch sofern
sie ihre fragen nicht direkt an jemanden
adressieren wird immer nur einen
vertreter eine vertreterin pro partei
antworten die erste frage kommen von
herrn rinke von reuters bitteschön ich
habe eine frage an den scholz noch mal
zu dem finanzierungs aspekt absage an
eine veränderte schuldenbremse und
steuererhöhungen wie wollen sie
sicherstellen dass diese vielen vorhaben
die ja auch mit drin stehen jetzt
finanziert werden können weil im
wahlkampf was ja so klang als ob das
eigentlich mit dieser doppelten absage
nicht funktionieren können können sie
das etwas erläutern bitte
wir haben
den großen gespräch mit den bürgerinnen
bürgern unterschiedliche vorschläge
gehabt wie wir das steuersystem besser
austarieren können aber die vorschläge
die dort gemacht worden sind sind
größtenteils nicht darauf gegangen
mehreinnahmen des staates zu
organisieren mit dem was wir jetzt hier
miteinander vereinbart haben besteht der
fiskalische spielraum den wir brauchen
für das was notwendig ist das betrifft
die investitionen die wir brauchen auch
die anderen fragestellungen dieser
aufgegriffen sind und selbstverständlich
glauben wir dass wir in diesem rahmen
das alles realisieren können
die nächste frage kommen von herrn ismar
vom tagesspiegel ja ich hätte auch noch
mal ganz kurz eine frage an sie herr
scholz ein zentrales thema des
wahlkampfes war respekt und
gerechtigkeit und sie haben natürlich
auch sehr stark damit geworben dass die
reichen in diesem land einen kleinen
oder etwas höheren beitrag leisten
sollen man sieht jetzt schon sehr viel
kritik auch vom linken parteiflügel dass
es das nicht gibt fürchten sie da
probleme und bedauern sie dass sie sich
da nicht durchsetzen können konnten und
an herrn lindner vielleicht die gleiche
frage noch mal von herrn rinke wie
wollen sie die gewaltigen zukunft in der
das investitions sicherstellen wenn man
ab 2023 zur schuldenbremse zurückkehrt
respekt ist die ganz große
herausforderung für das miteinander in
unserer gesellschaft das halte ich für
ganz ganz zentral dass wir im 21
jahrhundert es schaffen dass das
miteinander wieder eine größere rolle
spielt dass die bürgern am bürger
einander auf augenhöhe begegnen dass
niemand sich als etwas besseres
empfindet und das ist genau das was mit
den
zielsetzungen die wir verfolgt haben und
die sich wiederfinden auch angesprochen
ist zum beispiel die frage des
mindestlohnes zum beispiel die frage
ordentlicher tarifverträge und
ordentlicher bezahlung zum beispiel dass
man sich darauf verlassen kann dass es
ein stabiles rentenniveau gibt zum
beispiel dass wir genügend und auch
bezahlbare wohnungen bauen so dass man
gut zurechtkommen kann zum beispiel die
frage einer besseren perspektive für die
kinder all die themen über die wir
öffentlich gesprochen haben und die auch
jetzt eine rolle spielen insofern ist
das eine aufgabe die wir lösen werden
denn das geht ja um einzelne konkrete
politik die wir umsetzen wollen aber es
geht auch darum dass wir das miteinander
organisieren als eine gesellschaft die
zusammenhält und in der jeder seinen
beitrag leisten kann und jeder egal ob
man rechtsanwalt ist oder eben dafür
sorgt dass das essen auf den tisch kommt
und dass die lebensmittel verkauft
werden können im supermarkt oder dass
die bänder in den fabriken ordentlich
bestückt werden können alles das sind
die aufgaben die wir haben und das
werden wir gemeinsam so anpacken als
nächstes die creme es gab ja noch eine
frage an mich im sondierungs papier and
dem sondierungs papier und nehmen sie
viele vorhaben um soziale teilhabe und
sozialen aufstieg in deutschland zu
erleichtern
es ist ein gemeinsames ziel dass die
lebenschancen in unserem land nicht mehr
so stark von der familiären herkunft vom
zufall der geburt abhängen und da finden
sie vom bildungsbereich über einen
veränderten aufstiegsorientierten
sozialstaat viele gemeinsam getragene
anliegen und im sondierungs papier
finden sie ebenfalls zahlreiche
maßnahmen mit denen alle notwendigen
privaten und öffentlichen betone
privaten und öffentlichen
investitionsmittel
aktiviert werden können um
zukunftsaufgaben in deutschland zu
finanzieren als
nix ist der kollege von mir wollen wir
über welt fernsehen eine frage an
lindner frau weber hatte angedeutet dass
es noch gespräche gegeben hat bis tief
in die nacht was war das thema dann in
der nacht noch was als letzter sozusagen
vom eis geschoben worden ist und mussten
sich die parteivorsitzenden da noch
einmal einklinken es dann noch einmal
gespräche gegeben von denen wir nichts
wissen und vielleicht wenn ich darf noch
eine zweite frage wir wissen ja olaf
scholz oder kanzler werden aber wissen
ansonsten zu personalien ja nicht ist
dieses thema komplett umschifft worden
oder hat sich da eventuell etwas
abgezeichnet dass christian lindner
finanzminister wird robert habeck ja
auch was und probiere auch vielleicht
außenminister irgendetwas in der art
wurde da schon diskutiert wenn sie jetzt
noch nicht verraten wollen vielleicht
wurde das diskutiert
weber zu ihrer ersten frage die
generalsekretäre und der
bundesgeschäftsführer haben auf der
basis unserer gesprächsnotizen eine
beratungsgrundlage erarbeitet und diese
beratungsgrundlage haben wir gestern in
einer mehrstündigen intensiven
konstruktiven sitzung bis in die frühen
morgenstunden als parteivorsitzende
kanzlerkandidat
bearbeitet dabei kamen alle notwendigen
themen zur sprache zu ihrer zweiten
frage
trotz allem was sie gesagt haben ist das
ganze feld der finanzierung in dem
sondierungsteam ja doch hinreichend
konkret
gibt es konkrete absprachen die hier
nicht drin stehen oder müssen sie
tatsächlich über das konkrete noch sehr
ausführlich reden die zweite frage wie
groß ist die gefahr dass das ganze doch
noch in den koalitionsverhandlungen
scheitert
na ja das ist ja das ist ja sinn und
zweck von koalitionsverhandlungen dass
man auch noch was zu gesprächen hat
sonst wo ich dass diese
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht und
natürlich wird es bei den finanzen aber
auch bei allen anderen themenfeldern sie
sehen ja dass dieses papier relativ
knapp gefasst ist überall auch noch
konkretisierung geben und deswegen
werden wir jetzt allen unseren parteien
vorschlagen in diese
koalitionsverhandlungen gemeinsam
einzutreten und dann in dem geiste den
wir gerade beschrieben hatten der
letzten tage diese
koalitionsverhandlungen auch führen weil
es natürlich auch darum gehen wird dass
man sich nicht auf formelkompromisse und
den kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner
einigten das was wir an aufbruch für
dieses jahrzehnt der erneuerung brauchen
dann auch gemeinsam wirklich in die wege
leiten
frau becker bitte von der ard
eine frage an herrn habeck und einer
herrn lindner herr habeck soweit ich das
jetzt gesehen habe steht das tempolimit
nicht drin und co2 preise auch nicht
gelesen sondern emissionshandel wie
glücklich sind sie darüber und herr
lindner
aktien rente innerhalb der gesetzlichen
ist offensichtlich ist auch nicht
vorgesehen sondern als extra posten aber
dafür der mindestlohn 12 euro wie
glücklich sind sie mit diesen beiden
dingen wir haben das in unseren
statements harnisch
wir haben müssen und dann stellt man uns
angesprochen dieses papier zeichnet wir
haben es angesprochen dieses papier
zeichnet sich insgesamt dadurch aus dass
es sich bemüht eine klarheit zu schaffen
und so ist es richtig das tempolimit
konnten wir nicht durchsetzen an anderen
stellen sind wir sehr zufrieden wie der
text gearbeitet ist und das interessante
daran ist dass wir auch in diesen langen
stunden nicht in einem geiste sie ko
niederlage gedacht und gearbeitet haben
sondern das entstehen einer stabilen
grundlage von gemeinsamkeit und was die
frage von maßnahmen für den klimaschutz
angeht so sind wir der meinung dass das
sondierungs papier und die gespräche die
ist die dazu geführt haben ausreichend
maßnahmen nennt die dann in den
koalitionsgesprächen ausbuchstabiert
werden können um das paris ziel
einzuhalten und deutschland tatsächlich
in wenigen anderthalb jahrzehnten
klimaneutral machen zu können
dieses sondierungs papier enthält aus
unserer sicht äußerst
ambitionierte ideen damit deutschland
bald eine dekarbonisierung technologie
nation ist für uns ist das eine enorme
chance
wohlstand mit
ökologischer sensibilität zu verbinden
ich glaube dass keine andere
konstellation als diese in der lage ist
diese herausforderung zu stellen
deutschland kann vorbildhaft in europa
und der welt damit werden und zu ihrer
frage was die alterssicherung angeht
selbstverständlich können sie natürlich
so kurz das papier insgesamt noch nie
überblickt haben aber im spiel sieht nur
ein laden genau die passage zur
alterssicherung zum sozialstaat noch
einmal sich vorzulegen es gibt den
einstieg in eine teilweise
kapitaldeckung der gesetzlichen rente
wir wissen dass das für unsere
gesprächspartner ein großer schritt ist
und wir sind dankbar für diese
bereitschaft diesen schritt mit uns
gemeinsam zu gehen darüber hinaus haben
wir uns darauf verständigt auch die
private säule der altersversorgung zu
prüfen unterschiedliche instrumente die
das bisherige system der dritten säule
weiterentwickeln können miteinander zu
besprechen und wir haben verabredet den
sparerpauschbetrag
seit 2009 erst einmal wieder zu erhöhen
was für viele die etwa ein alternativer
anlageformen wie etf produkte sparen
ebenfalls entlastet also insgesamt ist
das was hier gelungen ist für unser land
eine sehr weitreichende bewegung und ich
will noch mal sagen dass ich sehr
dankbar bin dass wir auf sehr offene
gesprächspartnerinnen und
gesprächspartner getroffen sind
der mindestlohn ist hier verabredet das
war ein anliegen von spd und bündnis 90
die grünen das muss man akzeptieren dass
es hier an anliegen gibt und diesem
anliegen haben wir im sinne des gebens
und nehmens entsprochen wir sind
wiederum dankbar dass in diesem
zusammenhang eine verbesserung bei den
sogenannten midijobs und der einstieg in
die dynamisierung der höhe des mini jobs
möglich geworden ist das war ein weg den
unsere gesprächspartnerin und
gesprächspartner gegangen sind der uns
wiederum an entgegenkommen beim
mindestlohn sehr erleichtert auch dafür
bin ich sehr dankbar wenn ich das
alleine schon so darstelle parente und
beim mindestlohn sehen sie von welchem
geist diese gespräche geprägt waren es
ging nicht darum dass irgend jemandem
das leben erschwert werden soll es ging
nicht darum irgendjemanden
schwierigkeiten zu bereiten sondern ein
gutes für das land zu erreichen und das
ist in einer sehr beeindruckenden
balance gelungen ich will vielleicht
noch eines hinzufügen wer sich die
programme nebeneinander legt und dieses
papier dazu legte wird sehen dass es
abweichungen gibt das ist aber der sinn
dieser sondierungsgespräche und wer sie
sich anguckt wird sehen da ist nicht hat
sich nicht der eine zu lasten des
anderen durchgesetzt sondern ist mit
seinen jeweiligen schwerpunkten
christian lindner das angesprochen bei
uns das thema rente das thema
mindestlohn aber eben auch das thema
bezahlbarer wohnraum das hat sich ja
zusammengefügt mit den überlegungen der
jeweils anderen partner und ihren
schwerpunkten nicht zu einem
sammelsurium sondern eben zu einem
gemeinsamen ganzen und ich glaube das
macht den charme dieses papiers aus es
gibt den rahmen der jetzt gefüllt werden
kann mit vielen konkreten punkten mit
denen die jeweiligen parteien leben
können aber ich sage es noch mal nicht
weil sie jeweils ihre wählerinnen und
wähler bedienen müssen sondern weil wir
was für dieses land tun müssen und das
ist unser gemeinsames verständnis ich
finde dafür ist das ein sehr guter
rahmen mit sehr guten zielen die darin
beschrieben sind weil es geht am ende
darum dass wir den wohlstand sichern und
dabei alle mitnehmen der kollege im
grand prix
wie möglich wollen die general anzeiger
lindner weil ich vermute dass die fdp
den längsten weg hierzu hat zurücklegen
müssen ich würde gern wissen ob sie sich
in der konstellation wie sie sich jetzt
derzeit darstellt wohlfühlen ob sie das
spiel dort haben wo sie es haben wollten
und von spd und grünen wüsste ich gerne
wie schmerzhaft es für sie jeweils ist
dass die vermögenssteuer nicht kommt
wir sind eine eigenständige partei und
wir bemessen unseren eintritt in
koalitionen danach wo wir viel liberale
politik umsetzen können und wir sind
sehr zufrieden mit den möglichkeiten die
wir hier gemeinsam gefunden haben uns
gefällt das regierungspapier aufbruch
und fortschritt für deutschland sind
möglich und die dinge die uns wichtig
sind auch
kann ich nur wiederholen alle haben
gegen alle haben auch in den bereichen
wo es wirklich einen aufbruch und
fortschritt braucht und das leitmotiv
eine gesellschaft auf der höhe unserer
zeit auch in der zukünftigen politik und
der zukünftigen regierung wieder zu
spielen das ist der geist den dieses
papier gemeinsam arbeit atmet und zwar
für alle generationen in unserem land
und über die finanzierung haben wir
jetzt ja mehrfach gesagt dass wir die
investitionen dafür gemeinsam durch
unterschiedliche instrumente
bereitstellen
der kollege im blauen pullover bitte
buchsteiner
buchsteiner von pioneer herr scholz wie
ist jetzt das weitere setting für die
verhandlungen ist ein
verhandlungsabschluss vor weihnachten
weiterhin eine kanzlerwahl vor
weihnachten weiterhin realistisch dass
weitere setting wird besprochen wenn die
parteien alle miteinander ihre
entscheidung alle nachbarn an der
entscheidung getroffen haben das wird
wenn alles so läuft wie wir uns das
glaube ich miteinander gedacht haben
irgendwann am montag der fall sein und
dann werden auch die generalsekretäre
und bundesgeschäftsführer die
entsprechenden vorbereitungen für die
nächsten politischen für die
koalitionsgespräche und ähnliches
treffen können vorher gar nicht
sinnvollerweise und dass wir schnell
fertig werden wollen und das vor
weihnachten das hat glaube ich jede und
jeder von uns irgendwo schon mal gesagt
frau wiedemann ja bitte ja ich würde
gerne mal nachfragen bei den finanzen
also da habe ich bisher wenig konkretes
gehört finden hier auch kaum zahlen in
dem papier aber vielleicht habe ich auch
übersehen deswegen noch mal die frage
gibt es ganz konkrete zahlen wie hoch
ist der investitionsbedarf beim thema
klimaschutz zum beispiel und da sie ja
die schuldenbremse weiter einhalten
wollen wie groß sind die summen die sie
auf anderem wege dann irgendwie
zusammenbekommen
der konkrete finanzbedarf war jetzt
nicht bestandteil unserer
sondierungsgespräche sondern
die gemeinsame verabredungen wie es uns
gelingen kann dass wir sowohl private
als auch öffentliche investitionen auch
tatsächlich auf den weg bringen dazu ist
es dringend notwendig dass wir planungs
und genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen
dass wir die umsetzung von vorhaben
beschleunigen und dazu haben wir uns die
modernisierung des staates und der
verwaltung vorgenommen es ist glaube ich
der wichtigere hebel natürlich sind
investitionen notwendig in die zukunft
dieses landes in die transformation die
wir uns vorgenommen haben aber wir sind
zuversichtlich dass wir dafür die mittel
aufbringen werden
wir kommen zur letzten frage hier
bitteschön
paniert discovery los für den
deutschlandfunk eine frage an herrn
scholz und an die übrigen auch
spd-parteivorsitzenden die beiden sie
haben bezahlbares wohnen erwähnt sie
haben damit wahlkampf gemacht zu haben
unter den blüten moratorium gefordert
davon steht jetzt nichts mehr drin
sondern dass man bestehende mit schutz
regelungen evaluieren verlängern möchte
können sie sagen ist das mieten
moratorium oder einer begrenzung der
mieten dann komplett vom tisch oder
hoffen sie dass den
koalitionsverhandlungen da noch was
rausholen können danke wir haben
zunächst mal dafür sorge getragen dass
die drängende frage des fehlenden
wohnraums aufgegriffen wird wir haben
ein bündnis für das wohnen vorgesehen
dass wir alle gemeinsam richtig finden
dass er bei uns ein ganz besonderes
anliegen war denn es kommt bei der
lösung dieses problems zunächst einmal
darauf an dass man etwas macht dann
müssen nämlich alle zusammen arbeiten
die gemeinden in deutschland den kleinen
städte die großen städte landkreise die
16 länder der bund da müssen die
bauindustrie die wohnungswirtschaft die
mieterinnen und mieter miteinander
kooperieren und wir müssen uns jeden tag
darum kümmern dass wir die notwendige
mobilisierung zustande kriegen damit es
400.000 wohnungen pro jahr gibt viele
viele jahre lang und darunter 100.000
sozialwohnungen sind das ist die
wichtigste maßnahme wir haben sehr viele
mit schutz rechtliche regelungen die
sich dort wiederfinden wo wir gesagt
haben wir werden sie evaluieren das ist
das eine was wichtig ist und genau auf
ihre frage zielt und das zweite ist dass
wir natürlich auch die mit schutz
rechtlichen regelungen die befristet
sind verlängern wollen dass sie zwei
dinge die genau hier stattfinden und die
auch das gesamte setting für unseren
handlungsrahmen abgeben den wir dort
haben denn wir müssen und wir werden das
problem aufgreifen den wohnraummangel
und die steigenden preise
den wohnraummangel zu bekämpfen die
steigenden preise auch zu bekämpfen
indem wir dafür sorgen dass es genügend
wohnungen gibt und an ausreichenden
mieterschutz
sodann bedanken wir uns herzlich
willkommen für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen tag
tschüss
soweit also die pressekonferenz am ende
der sondierungsgespräche zwischen spd
grünen und fdp mit den
parteivorsitzenden der drei beteiligten
parteien aber natürlich auch mit dem
kanzlerkandidaten der spd der ja kanzler
werden soll wenn die koalitionsgespräche
vorüber sind und die einen erfolgreichen
abschluss genommen haben wir haben große
worte gehört hier in der vergangenen
halben stunde es wird von dem größten
modernisierungs schritt für deutschland
seit 100 jahren die rede beispielsweise
bei einer phobie olaf scholz annalena
baerbock hat von einer modernisierungs
jetzt von einem erneuerungs jahrzehnt
gesprochen und christian lindner der
fdp-vorsitzende dass es noch nie oder
schon lange nicht mehr so große
reformschritte gegeben hat in start in
gesellschaft und in der wirtschaft und
das ist das was diese drei koalitionäre
anteilen sie sind mit unterschiedlichen
voraussetzungen in den wahlkampf
gegangen sie haben höchst
unterschiedliche parteiprogramme sie
hatten unterschiedliche wahlprogramme
aber sie haben sich zusammengerauft
offenbar in den vergangenen 14 tagen und
ein gemeinsames papier verabschiedet
teilweise beraten bis in die späte nacht
hinein aber sie haben ein papier
zusammen geschrieben von dem sie sagen
es ist eine grundlage auf der man in
koalitionsgespräche gehen kann es hat
ein paar beispiele gegeben schon wie
hier genannt worden sind beispielsweise
verzichten sowohl spd als auch bündnis
90 die grünen auf ein tempolimit von 130
im sinne des klimaschutzes und auf der
anderen seite gesteht christian lindner
den beteiligten zu dass es einen
mindestlohn geben soll wie
beispielsweise von spd und grünen
gewünscht wird dazwischen viele andere
beispiele noch die hier man gemeinsam
auf den weg bringen will entscheidend so
haben sie alle drei gesagt sein dass man
was nach vorne bringen kann dass man
reformen dass man reformen schaffen kann
in den nächsten vier jahren und da ist
dann an der einen und anderen stelle
eben auch schon mal das jeweils eigene
wahlprogramm ein klein wenig zumindest
auch oder in einzelnen punkten in den
hintergrund getreten hans-werner also
ich darf das noch ergeben sich aus dem
studio in born also wirklich hatte
christian lindner dann gesagt die
letzten tage waren geprägt von einem
besonderen politischen stil allein diese
stil markiert schon eine zäsur in der
politischen kultur deutschlands das kann
man ja so interpretieren dass er damit
der union noch mal eins mitgegeben hat
er hat sie haben ja ein teil der dinge
die da jetzt vorgestellt worden sind
schon angesprochen offenbar haben ja
alle seiten zugeständnisse gemacht an
die jeweils andere seite es gibt
mindestlohn haben sie schon erwähnt es
gibt den einstieg in eine kapitaldeckung
der rente das sagt sich ja immer so
leicht wenn man sich diese
spitzenpolitiker hört wir mussten alle
aufeinander zugehen aber so auf den
ersten blick uns liegt leider dieses
zwölf seiten papier her in bonn noch
nicht vor hat man wirklich den eindruck
die sind tatsächlich alle aufeinander
zugegangen oder
genau so sieht das aus wir haben das
zwölf seiten papier hans-werner hier
liegen ja ich hatte keine gelegenheit
weiter rein zu gucken deswegen haben wir
ein zwei punkte gesehen beispielsweise
das hartz4 tatsächlich abgeschafft
werden soll dass es stattdessen ein
bürgergeld geben soll darüber hat man
sich verständigt aber und wir haben es
eben in der pressekonferenz ja auch
gehört viele viele punkte sind natürlich
noch zu klären in den kommenden wochen
beispielsweise war stand ja die frage im
raum wie viel geld braucht sie
eigentlich für die projekte die die er
davor habt ist es ja nur gesagt worden
dass man steuern nicht erhöhen will und
dass man trotzdem möglichkeiten genug
hat um all die dinge zu finanzieren
dabei scheint noch offen zu sein die
frage wie viel man denn tatsächlich
braucht es gab ja in den vergangenen
tagen da durchaus hinweise dass sich der
bund noch bundesfinanzminister
auch andere finanzquellen erschlossen
hat beispielsweise über die
mindestbesteuerung von großen von
international agierenden unternehmen
rechnet das ifo-institut von 5 bis 6
milliarden euro im jahr damit kann man
natürlich sehr gut arbeiten zu an dem
einen oder anderen punkt aber es wird
sicherlich
da noch ein größerer bedarf seien
offenbar will man auch viele
subventionen abschaffen aber das werden
wir im detail noch genauer gucken und
auch lesen müssen und andere punkte
wiederum werden die koalitionäre in
ihren gesprächen noch beschließen müssen
da hat man sicher noch viele punkte
offen auch wenn man jetzt die grundlage
gelegt hat für eine koalition zusammen
zu würde zumindest für gespräche muss
man ja korrekter weise sagen in der tat
und das ist wichtig und das ist gut dass
sie das auch noch mal betonen diese
gespräche haben und einem anderen stil
in einem anderen umgang stattgefunden
man hat aufeinander gehört das ist ja
auch gesagt worden dass von christian
lindner ist das spannend gewesen auch
mal zu hören wo die anderen wichtige
punkte sehen wo sie wichtige punkte oder
wo punkte sind die für sie wichtig sind
und norbert walter borjans hat betont es
sei ganz wichtig und entscheidend
gewesen dass man eben über das was man
für die eigene partei erreichen will
hinaus guckt sag ich währenddessen
gerade hinter mir die treppe rolltreppe
runter gefahren ist es sei wichtig
gewesen auch nicht nur die eigenen
wählerschaft im blick zu haben sondern
auch die wählerinnen und wähler der
anderen parteien die hier beteiligt sind
und sogar die wählerinnen und wähler des
ganzen landes denn das und dann sind wir
wieder bei christian hinter all das was
man hier besprochen hat und was man
vorhat gemeinsam was man erreichen will
soll den ganzen land dienen und eben
auch staat gesellschaft und wirtschaft
ja die politischen freunde dieser drei
ampel sondierung spricht die drei
parteien werden sich das ja jetzt im
laufe des tages genauer anschauen genau
wie wir journalisten und das
kleingedruckte lesen so ist denn da
schon geschrieben ist er hat wie geht es
denn jetzt weiter
wann werden sich die gremien damit
befassen und wann ist dann eventuell
schon am montag das war ja so ein
bisschen unklar schon mit richtigen
koalitionsverhandlungen zu rechnen
also mit dem montag als beginn der
koalitionsgespräche rechne ich nach dem
was ich gehört habe und wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe erstmal noch
nicht denn beispielsweise will ja wohl
die fdp ihre gremien am montag erst mit
dem ganzen vorgang befassen und dann
müssen sich die generalsekretäre und der
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen noch
mal zusammen tun um fahrplan zu
entwerfen für die kommenden tagen mal
zumindest für die kommende woche und da
wird man sehen wie es weiter wie es
weitergehen kann sicher ist das teil
einige gremien der beteiligten parteien
sich mittlerweile schon mit dem papier
mit den ergebnissen der beratungen aus
den vergangenen tagen befasst haben
beispielsweise ein erweitertes
sondierungsteam der grünen 24 köpfe
stark aber auch der parteirat ist schon
informiert worden dann wird am sonntag
der länder hat der kleine parteitag der
grünen zusammen kommen heute heißt es
gibt es auch eine schaltkonferenz der
spd-bundestagsfraktion auch die anderen
beteiligten fraktionen im bundestag der
hier beteiligten parteien werden sich
sicherlich austauschen oder informieren
lassen die spd so hieß es in den
vergangenen tagen wolle sowohl präsidium
als auch vorstand mit über die gespräche
informieren und auch da noch mal ein
votum einholen auch wenn es formal gar
nicht nötig wäre auch das wird wenn ich
das jetzt richtig leute am montag
geschehen sodass ich vermute dass wir am
dienstag vielleicht aber auch erst am
mittwoch dann in tatsächliche
koalitionsgespräche oder auf
tatsächliche koalitionsgespräche gucken
können schärfer vielen dank nach berlin
danke für diese analysen zu dieser
entscheidung in berlin ja liebe
zuschauer die spitzen der parteien sie
haben sie gerade hören können empfehlen
also ihren parteigremien die aufnahme
von koalitionsgesprächen also
möglicherweise geht es dann dienstag
oder mittwoch los und weil das unter
umständen eine historie historische
entscheidung werden kann dann nämlich
wenn es klappt dann wäre das nämlich die
erste ampel koalition in diesem land
schauen wir uns diese pressekonferenz
von gerade noch einmal in ihrer ganzen
euphorie